maintenant faire attention si la bulle
pourquoi c'est la plus dure mois si vous
êtes le meilleur
pourquoi il avait parlé alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter de pire en ce
moment que le réveil sonne et qu'on me
dise que tout ça n'était qu'un rêve
ouais quel des fous aimeriez vous avoir
la rancune samarie êtes un peu rancunier
mais c'est aussi tenace avait des
accords non savoir assez vite
quel est le cas l'encours vous
n'aimeriez pas avoir le talent donner
des ordres
ouais quelle est la qualité que vous
regrettez d'avoir tué un riche interview
je peux appeler ma femme la qualité
cassé c'est quoi la question la qualité
que vous regrettez d'avoir j'ai parfois
un peu trop consensuelle ouais en quoi
aimeriez-vous être beaucoup plus mauvais
beaucoup plus mauvais mais qui pense
qu'il est bon en tout je ne sais pas je
sais pas interview parue ce sens qui ne
voudriez vous pas avoir comme femme a un
paquet ouais j'ai bien
ses parents tous avoir à vous c'est vrai
vous je vous engage directement
prochaine noms qui servent à ne pas
avoir comme fans en bas il ya plein de
gens qui me vient à l'idée tient pas
rayonnant
par exemple mais n'ont pas réussi
henin qui me vient à l'esprit
ouais bah le borgne non mais justement
imagine imagine jean-marie en train de
chanter ya public
quels sont les défauts que doit avoir
une femme pour qu'elle vous séduisent
tous maintenant par tous j'ai toujours
peur parce que je re classe et je
reviens une phrase que j'avais dit un
jour comme ça on va dire qu'avec lé lock
et pour la femme idéale j celle dont
j'aimerais tous les défauts d'accord oui
voilà c'est ça celles dont les défauts
me paraissent charmant et voilà jusqu'au
jour où s'ils le sont moins bien c'est
bien
qu'est-ce qui vous donnerait envie
d'être trompé par une femme
allons bon ça lui viennent à l'esprit
ça lui vient à l'esprit au moment où je
sais pas comment la quitter voilà avec
leurs bonnes réponses quand avez vous
déjà été heureux d'être quittée bon bah
quand j'étais plus amoureux comme quand
tous les hommes un peu lâche j'ai laissé
pourrir way
quelle est l'insulté qui vous a fait le
plus plaisir [ __ ] ouais bravo
quel est le compliment qui vous énerve
le plus c'est sa part est arrivé ya pas
longtemps dans un aéroport
j'adore vos chansons mais c'est jacques
brel ouais très bien sapés du commun le
mec jaloux c'est aussi avec francis
cabrel
qu'est ce que vous voudriez que vos
enfants rate beaucoup de choses pour que
pour qu'ils aient la la notion de
l'échec pour pouvoir apprécier mieux
l'éventuel succès enfin je sais pas si
c'est très clair ce pdg
ouais j'aurais plus de la troisième
guerre mondiale ah ouais la troisième
guerre mondiale
c'est vrai aussi passé jusque qui aimez
vous détestez laurent guillemassy si si
si les meilleurs et les les noms les
gars avec qui je joue au poker mais
voilà d'accord ça oui ça c'est les seuls
moments où on peut aimer détester
quelqu'un
ouais parce que dans la relation on est
obligé de détester quelqu'un qui est en
face de vous quand on veut quand on veut
gagner par qui aimeriez vous le détestez
détesté par une femme parce qu'il paraît
c'est un signe à dire sans raison
c'était comme ça sans raison
ça fait un signe de grande excitation
d'autant qu'elle est la récompense que
vous avez reçue qui ne vous honore pas 3
[ __ ] c'est super dur
quelle est leur récompense que j'ai reçu
le meneur pas avait il ya trois négation
de la formation dave avoir faut savoir
que huit ans de psychanalyse et d'avoir
été si gagner ça s'appelle la francisque
non il ya une récompense qui nous honore
pas oui les cris des femmes qui ont
simulé ah bravo ça m'étonnerait ceci
étant ça ne m'étonnerait qu'on simule
avait bien elles sont là ce soir
quelle est la meilleure mauvaises
critiques qu'on vous ait fait meilleur
mauvaises critiques meilleur mauvaise
critique meilleur mauvaises critiques
c est un chanteur populaire avait
peut-être est la pire bonnes critiques
la pire bonnes critiques c'est celle que
les gens vous font dans une loge quand
ils viennent nous voir au théâtre et qui
vous disent tu t'es formidable mais
c'est un rôle en or
ah ouais d'accord et c'est terry parce
que le rôle en or c'est qu'on l'a bien
fait et tu peux rien répond tu fais un
bon outil quel est votre plus belle
erreur de croire que tout est possible
et votre pire victoire c'est d'avoir de
n'avoir pas chanter dans les villes
front national et de penser aujourd'hui
que j'ai eu raison